[Music]
that men on Batman there is the news
ladies and gentlemen which means that
portion of the show is done that means
we're at the portion of the show that
everybody seems to like the Q&A portion
of the show man where we open it up to
you guys and find out what you want to
know and answer your questions
so oh the lights dramatically shifted
that was amazing
are you gonna be our first cue here lift
it up and speak right into just bear
down there we go there we go again use
your cocksuckin voice hello mark how are
you what's your name my name is Chris
Chris everyone give it up for Chris lazy
Joe first question of the night well
actually I wanted to first volunteer a
piece of trivia George has been the
shooting location for several films in
the past like dreamcatcher
double jeopardy and reindeer games which
had I didn't say they were either of
good movies but was the last one
reindeer games with Ben Affleck reindeer
games shot here yeah I met Affleck you
met Affleck as well that's what this was
a while ago and there was a lot of very
very attractive women behind me but
beside me so it was right after actually
was quite a bit after the Oscar Ryan I
couldn't think of anything else to say
so I said hey congratulations on the
Oscar and he said yeah thanks and he he
went on to everybody else so that was
the extent of my brush another film that
was shot here a long time ago which I
know you like is strange brew which one
strange brew strange brew shot here
absolutely really yep at the brewery
though so the whole movie or just the
note we have a brewery in town that's
been around for quite some time and they
shot a lot of the scenes of the brewery
all the Elsinore brewery stuff was shot
here yeah basically why because we had a
brewery I know but like there's a lot of
breweries in Canada oh I guess I was a
more Canadian where did they shoot the
rest of the movie I actually don't know
probably mostly in Vancouver Toronto I'm
sorry thank you Toronto and then they
came all the way the [ __ ] up here are
you sure about
this is a Barrett oh yeah I think you
guys have been lied to all these years
nobody bothered to check into it wow
that's incredible so they shot most of
it in Toronto and then came up here to
shoot yeah well we actually had a prison
that was unoccupied which is the reason
where we got double jeopardy and Ranger
Green Ranger two games and all what was
the first one you mentioned a dream
catcher dream catcher Jason Leigh was in
that movie yep oh my god I remember that
Laura Lawrence Kasdan picture yep
and that was set in the snow so they
shot her when it was well Ranger games
was the big one like that shot
everywhere which one reindeer games
now to the question I've actually had a
chance to actually ask this of Marc and
because this is relating to a tweet that
he had retweeted but basically okay
scream bye there we go but there was a
tweet that talked about ready player one
and saying that it was the geek version
of Black Panther paraphrasing not the
most appropriate tweet but I start sort
of thinking about if you had we know
about these watershed films that have
pushed the boundaries like Wonder Woman
in Black Panther if someone told you you
know we want to know which next 100
million dollar genre a superhero film
that it'll push that boundary which one
would you pick huh I might go safe and
go with Alpha Flight which does have yes
number one it's Canadian so of course
that plays well up here but I wasn't
going for like Canadian diversity I was
gone for a North Star is the first
openly gay comic book character so that
might be a way to kind of push the line
a little bit and you know you're not
going like come see the movie about the
gay superhero all by himself he's in a
team you know so maybe then it goes down
a little smoother and I didn't mean that
in a dirty way yeah yeah for those at
home or like I don't like my superheroes
gay and then you give them a [ __ ]
team picture and the bun characters gay
and then they walk out of the movie
going I love gay superheroes more
surely that's my dream about you Plus to
be able to be involved with Alpha Flight
like like it's been my endeavor in this
lifetime I don't know if people have
noticed over the course the last 25
years to really endear myself to the
Canadian people I'm a big fan of the
country and secretly in the back of my
mind I've always been like one day
America is going to hell so I'm gonna
need a place to go so if I you know thus
far I've done the big into hockey I wear
jerseys and stuff like that I was on
[ __ ] Degrassi so like I think if I
could be like and I made Alpha Flight
they make me Prime Minister for Christ
sakes
[Applause]
my pics I to pics shang-chi from Marvel
oh so smart oh my god you're way smarter
than me well I'm not sure they're not
gonna let me into China but like smart
like to do an Asian superhero to do an
Asian superhero to both play into and
subvert the the already existent sort of
tropes and stereotypes that exist on the
page but make them real make them make
these characters real make them deep and
absolutely play to that audience which
is historically underserved especially
in America or or Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes
that the Keith Giffen version because
again you know America in about 20 years
is going to be more Hispanic than any
other any other sort of class of people
and there's never been there were rarely
movies targeting that demographic
audience other than Zorro a can think of
Xaro kinda and like Selena and la Bamba
and that's like those were not superhero
movies
Richie Valens is a superhero I don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
hey I guess airplanes were his
kryptonite though
what too [ __ ] soon but uh but yeah
those are my picks but I like Alpha
Flight now if a flight is a really good
call yeah yeah it's a safe call yours
was a yours was risky ballsy chancy what
was the first one
yours were ballsier than mine my friend
thank you you were the the fat you
always brought up like back when they
were making iron fist that would have
been the perfect opportunity to make
that an asian superhero instead they
made him the guy from Game of Thrones
right did you ever finish watching Iron
Fist I did DJ yeah sorry yeah I gave him
all the time at the end I got really
excited cuz they like there's a dragon
under New York and I was like holy [ __ ]
I've sat here for 13 painful [ __ ]
hours I'm gonna get a dragon I had a
dragon on Game of Thrones last week I'm
gonna get a dragon on Iron Fist and it
was dragon bones
there was no dragon I was like god damn
it Iron Fist
you aren't fisted made ya so good oh
yeah I was fantastic I just want to see
one more thing about how inspirational
you've been to me personally as both as
a person in the media but also as an
individual and I said in an article I
wrote about mark
that thanks to you Mark's becoming the
writer I want to be but consequently
it's making you the man I want to be so
I wanted to thank you for that oh oh
thank you
it means the world I like when people
like what I do but I like when you can
impact a more like that like that's
[ __ ] meaningful thank you hey man how
are you
good [ __ ] that was amazing so you better
[ __ ] come with something as deep and
powerful as that it's powerful but it's
not as deep as what I'm said how are you
sir I'm good thank you
I have a couple questions for you Kevin
far away
I actually met you in Vancouver
at an expo and I was dressed as stitch
oh right on your big stitch fan I see
him on the shirt my crista nice well
done um I just wanted to say thank you
for meeting with me it was a great
experience
this is actually my very first panel
asking questions actually so this is
really cool I have a couple questions
first what's up with Jay and Silent Bob
I got the meet Ming and he told me that
you're doing a reboot Jay & Silent Bob
yeah we're doing a sequel to Jay and
Silent Bob strike back and it's called
Jay and Silent Bob reboot Jay and it's
it's us it's it's me and Jay so it's not
really strictly a reboot in the way that
people think of as a reboot if you
remember Jay and Silent Bob strike back
it was a movie in which Jay and Silent
Bob found out that Hollywood was making
a movie about them so they went
cross-country to Hollywood to stop that
movie from happening Jay and Silent Bob
reboot is completely [ __ ] different
in Jay and Silent Bob reboot Jay and
Silent Bob find out that Hollywood is
making a reboot of that old movie that
they had made about them and they have
to go across the country to Hollywood to
stop it all over again it's it's
literally the same [ __ ] movie all
over again it's a movie that makes fun
of sequels and remakes and reboots while
being all three at the same time so I
for me like one of my favorite little
director [ __ ] trip tricks or or
experiments of the last you know I don't
know 20 [ __ ] years 25 years was Gus
Van Sant
the wonderful director he's coming off
the heat of Good Will Hunting
you know he's an Academy Award nominated
director the movie won awards been a
matte one for screenwriting Robin won
for acting and it great Robin Williams
so Gus had his pick of anything he could
do anything he wanted
and he went into Universal and he was
like I'm gonna I want to remake psycho
and they were like are you crazy that's
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho and he's like
yeah but it's a black-and-white movie
and nobody really watches it anymore
there's a generation of kids that'll
never know this movie so it's like
clerks I want to do totally I can't wait
till the color remake of clerks any
minute now I was like I like I thought
that was so crazy
ballsy he wanted to do a shot-for-shot
remake of psycho but just in color like
with new actors that was it and it's a
very film school experiment like a film
school type thing like it's something
like a young [ __ ] buck director who's
like figuring out what they want to be
and you know does I want to [ __ ] do
something avant-garde it felt very
avant-garde
and some people will argue from now it's
at the end of time that it was
absolutely [ __ ] unnecessary and blah
blah blah but I liked that like it was
just ballsy cuz he literally just made
the same [ __ ] movie over again and
stuff so mine's not that strictly it's
not we have a completely different
script but I used the script to Jay and
Silent Bob strike back to build the
script to Jay and Silent Bob reboot so
like there's a van in it with three
girls in it
can you tell is it the date of that
movie or when you're gonna shoot it
start shooting in August
Wow yeah so hopefully by 2019 you'll be
able to to see it is there gonna be a
clerk three there was going to be I
wrote it and I wanted to do it but one
of the cast didn't want to do it without
that person we can't make it so no so I
might miss a comic book script instead
and I last one because yeah last one is
they're good I love comic movement it's
my favorite TV show on AMC and I hope it
gets more seasons but my question is is
there gonna be any release date for any
DVDs on each season what a great
question I've been asking that for years
and they're like wow well maybe when
we're done and I'm like what like you
know I gotta wait that long so I
they've never wanted to do
a box of the DVDs or anything because
their feeling is like people can stream
it people can watch it on our AMC
network on their website or whatnot but
III don't know they it's it's weird they
don't want to make they don't think that
there's a market for DVDs in general and
DVDs of comic book men in particular so
maybe when it's all done one day they'll
put it all out on DVD or something and I
just want to say thank you for being
here I heard about you in the hospital I
have the same thing who heard about my
heart attack I did news traveled up here
as well yeah and some [ __ ] carrier
pigeon came up here and but I have kind
of similar I have a brain injury brain
injury that I drowned in a pool when I
was four with my brother but he died but
I'm still alive so I'm kind of like you
used to buy a heart attack i surrounded
Ronnie or [ __ ] survivors yeah yeah
yeah thank you and your movies helped me
they're rude and I just I actually got
my dad to watch clerks 1 and then I had
to watching number 2 he said number two
was better one was like oh he fell
asleep during half of clerks one that
really hurt my father fell asleep
watching chasing amy I watched him fall
asleep he nodded out and she was really
surprised with that one to psych I don't
want to say the name cuz I mean there's
a black person here so that's that big
word oh yeah yeah so my daddy I don't
know if you do that but there's a there
is their questionable language cuz I
guess some questionable language in the
movie is well thank you very much and I
hope you are here for a lot more and I
hope the whole crowd here is thankful
that your life too right crowd oh my god
you're very sweet thank you thank you so
much thank you bye bye
ha ha hello and you're [ __ ] I want to
take you home
you wouldn't [ __ ] survive a minute in
Los Angeles but I want to bring you
there somebody so you been there you
made it a lot out alive you went to
Disneyland is not Los Angeles this place
on earth Los Angeles scariest Seguin
that's right well yeah you'll be able to
listen to it we'll put it up this week
you'll be able to hear it sweet all
right how are you man hey I'm doing
great I don't know how the [ __ ] to have
come after these two young guys I know
there's the bar is high well first of
all I grew up watching Kevin Smith
movies Silent Bob I met Jason Mewes when
he was up hang on you came last year
yeah that's right he had warned me in
advance
yeah I'm surprised I was going to Prince
George he goes Oh as it was I this far
that's a guy I'm sure it's not far he's
[ __ ] right whose bar my question is
actually picking up back off now that
your front loaded with the reindeer
games
okay would you ever reboot reindeer
games
casting Matt Damon and Jay and Silent
Bob so wait we redo reindeer games but
without a flick and instead we cast Matt
Damon his best friend and [ __ ] and we
see if he notices can we invite him to
the premiere I think so I think you have
to add another meta joke when I was in
the theater watching Jay and Silent Bob
strike back when it first came out right
that line where Matt Damon looks at Ben
Affleck and says and sometimes you do
reindeer games biggest laugh you had a
standing I would imagine here yeah if
you like always [ __ ] they made it here
we yeah man I would mean [ __ ] if
somebody was like here's a bunch of
money and you could do whatever you want
[ __ ] Jay and Silent Bob reboot that's
the film school experiment that's worth
my time
free shot remake of reindeer Affleck
would have to talk to me after that you
know look why did you do this medicals
some men just want to watch the world
burn I once shot a man just for snoring
is that is that good that covers it
brilliant man excellent meeting you give
it up for a my gentlemen how are you
good sir come right up to that mic
especially cuz I'm here today in front
of you to your liking this is why now
Prince George is on the map that's where
Silent Bob died Jay like no no not Jay
some other guy they did a podcast Robin
unnamed a black man we've only got three
how are you I'm doing great I have three
questions for you fire away with the
ending of in penny wars and the fact
that you write into the mic so they can
all hear with the ending of infinity
wars and the fact that literally half
the universe is now dead what do you
think the fallout of that is gonna be
with the rest of the Marvel Universe
with like North Netflix and the
defenders and I know was the Punishers
currently filming if not just finishing
up here now and Luke Cage comes out next
month so I doubt it gets referenced on
Luke Cage I hear they're referencing in
on agents of shield where there was a
reference last week that was like an
infinity war reference some buddies I've
read that online in passing I don't
think it'll show up in the Netflix shows
okay I think now that they're kind of up
and running and they've had their own
audiences like in the first season they
would mention like the Indians and stuff
like that but I don't now that they've
got their own footing I feel like
they're not going to do that they're
very separate those companies are
completely separated
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe
people that run that Kevin Feige and
whatnot really don't interact with the
TV division that Jeph Loeb runs and
stuff so there's no like hey man we're
doing this you know put it in the TV
shows or vice versa if the TV shows
follow the movies they follow them like
they know what's in development what's
happening and they'll sprinkle in some
stuff but they don't really cross over
that much so I doubt you'll see it in
any of the Netflix shows I'd be all for
it if they did it that would be so
[ __ ] dope but I can fish just wasn't
an iron fist he just goes away you can
use that movie to collect a lot of
[ __ ] mistakes man he can skip like two
seasons of true and then just becomes
Dora the dragon and that's all we get on
board yeah it'd just be better though if
everyone forgot about him too so they
weren't all like where's Iron Fist you
know instead they were just like hey
remember when we did [ __ ] without that
guy or something he didn't come back a
flawed soul stoned and he's [ __ ]
trapped let me out Luke Cage nah man
that's him doing this [ __ ] exercises
I've been working on my Iron Fist
impression I'm workshopping it is that
good that fantastic answer to that
second question just a piggyback off the
gentleman in front of me with black
lives matters and with Black Panther and
the whole more so racial epidemic the
more racial view that Marvel Comics is
going if you will Jay and Silent Bob
reboot have Hooper X in it
oh no but it let me see how to explain
this let me read you a line from the
movie that actually kind of references
that sort of thing
so I won't be here now little tiny sneak
peek just it's little taste and we got
cut this out of the podcast it's just
for you Prince
it really is you're welcome so in the
scene in the movie where based on that
line the movie like basically we set up
the whole movie and like you know like
we make jokes about other movies and
then follow through and make the jokes
on ourselves so the three girls this
time are so painfully [ __ ] diverse
like it's crazy last time the girls were
like is a [ __ ] quartet of white
chicks and this time it's incredibly all
over the map and stuff and it's
commented on all the time so it's it's
just it's full of jokes like that meta
jokes like that so Hooper ex won't be
back but yes they'll definitely be a
acknowledgement of the the world we live
in today as opposed to the world we
lived in when I made that movie almost
20 years ago I like to imagine Hooper X
is kind of like old and bitter like
James Baldwin living in Paris you know
just talking about like let me tell you
about the homosexual life no man he's
happy like [ __ ] number one like he
could be out like in a way that he
wasn't in 1997 and stuff indie comics
you know are huge you get rich off it in
my version of what happens to her ex his
comic book became a major motion picture
he got rich good for him no still angry
though it wasn't really angry though
he's faking it well done give it up for
my how are you good sir what can we do
for you I'm doing very well thank you
both for being here
I have one question but it's sort of
split into two parts okay one half for
each of you if that's okay fantastic
I'm part of a northern BC fledgling film
company we just made our first feature
film which I wrote the screenplay for
and it's a gnat's
oh what's it called it's called the
doctor's case
I've heard about this feature film and
it's an adaptation of a Stephen King
short story about Sherlock Holmes and
dr. Watson right on so it was a blast to
do it it's part of Kings dollar baby
initiative which allows you what does
that explain that for those like me that
don't know what that is and so in 1977
Stephen King started as part of his
foundation an opportunity for emerging
filmmakers to legally adapt one of his
non licensed short stories and he would
give you the non-commercial rights for a
dollar and you have a year to make the
film and and then you can show it at
festivals other nonprofit venues that
sort of thing you just can't sell it to
anybody it's awesome yeah it's a great
program it's been running for 40 years
Frank Darabont when he was 23 actually
adapted Kings the woman in the room and
that was the first of three dollar
babies that got a bit of a not really a
commercial distribution but it was a
more widely distributed film but that's
how his relationship with King started
and then later on Shaw and Green Mile
Wow yeah mmm is the mist as well yeah
absolutely so we had an opportunity to
adapt the Sherlock Holmes story as I
think why did these people do they know
they've seen it many people have seen it
for sure a lot of them were our
crowdfunding supporters as well we had a
huge Kickstarter campaign that allowed
us to to make fifty percent of the money
to go down and make the film and then
within the year we had it done and sent
off to King and it's only just now being
shown like we had our world premiere at
the Julien Dubuque International Film
Festival [ __ ] fantastic so well thank
you
but the question was is because in
adapting the story I was I tried to be
as faithful as I possibly could to
King's actual writing because I do find
sometimes people take the plots and the
characters and then they leave the
writing behind and the writing seems to
be one of the things that makes King as
popular as he is the actual words that
he rides yes and also balancing
something that isn't such an iconic
character like Sherlock Holmes and
knowing you're working on Castle Rock
and you obviously I mean you directed
the flash you wrote Superman lives which
too bad we didn't get a chance to see
but I just wondered about that like the
the idea of writing for something that
is so iconic that people have real
priests preconceived notions of what it
is that should be and then also adapting
somebody else's literary work for
television and how that how much of the
process is about preserving the style of
writing and then balancing it against
something like jumping into a world that
everybody knows that make sense is yes
only you handle the King part okay so
you're I'll do that bit yeah for us and
for those that don't follow mark has
been working on a show called Castle
Rock which is how would you describe it
it is set in the world of Stephen King
it'll be it's JJ who's producing in
Stephen King gave green lights for all
of that stuff it'll be on Hulu and then
I think I know you guys don't get hulu
up here but I think Warner Brothers
International was selling it all over
the world because they need to make
their money because they spent a lot of
[ __ ] money
but for us we the process was very much
about figuring out who Stephen King was
as a writer and what Stephen King
stories felt like you know it's easy to
think as many of us do this Stephen King
as a horror writer but that's not
actually what he's best at that's not
actually the books you love the stories
you love from Stephen King are very
frequently not the scary ones the most
popular Stephen King story the most
popular adaptation of a Stephen King
story by far is the Shawshank Redemption
which is not horror it is not scary it
is that there's some creepy parts in it
for sure but he's a character writer and
he finds ways to build and sketch him
and deliver characters in very real ways
and put them up against their personal
greatest fears that is nothing not a
scary thing you know stand by me is the
other one and that is not scary except
that it's about kids confronting the
idea of death for the first time but
it's not about shocking either no jump
scares it's not that kind of story he's
not actually that kind of storyteller
you know we as we were trying to build
what a season of TV would feel like it
was more like let's find
the the the lost Stephen King novel
it wasn't about like let's take Jack
Torrance from here and Annie Wilkes from
here and Cujo from here and rammed them
all together it was let us distill what
make Stephen King great and find a way
to push a story forward that feels like
it came from his pen but never did and
so for us it was about reading the work
and discovering the the inner workings
of the work and realizing that he's not
a mystery writer he is a character
writer who also deals in mystery and
that's why he's so popular it's a
fantastic [ __ ] answer
I I can't follow that I've never thought
that deeply about anything in my life
not even my marriage what was the
question to me I'm just about that
dealing with an iconic character like
Sherlock Holmes or Superman or the flash
or when you're working within such a
well-known and well-loved universe but
still having your own ability to bring
some life into those carry well it's a
respect issue right like so yeah I go to
the flash I don't go ooh you know what
the flash should say this week he should
call [ __ ] the elongated man a [ __ ]
smoker you know like that would be me
inflicting my tastes on the show I don't
I don't really do that because I like
the show number one and because I like
the source material the characters I
come up there trying to be protective of
that material more than anything else
but when I wrote like Superman lives
back in 96 there was like I haven't read
in a long time but if I remember it
being way more me than them you know I
kept Superman as Superman as I could but
my voice is like way in there and stuff
I don't think I would do that if I was
doing that again you wouldn't hear me as
much in it and not because I'm like all
I'm ashamed of my voice but you just
want to honor the material there's so
many great [ __ ] stories that have
been told with these characters that you
don't have to be like well here's my
Kevin Smith version I the Kevin Smith
would prefer to take a greatest hits
compilation of stories that [ __ ]
captured his imagination as a kid so if
I were to a
tapped again and I haven't I don't mean
let me see I did a script for Sam and
twitch but there wasn't a lot to be
faithful to and what else have I done I
did a plastic man script like two years
ago for an animated show and you know
that's very easy to be true to just be
goofy and [ __ ] like that
so I would imagine I would I be more
reverent especially as a writer as you
know I always try to put the shoe on the
other foot so if somebody was like hey
I'm writing Jay and Silent Bob you know
I'd be like god I hope they do it the
way I would do it and not like just do
their own thing or something like that
so I try to give that back if I was ever
touching somebody else's character good
thank you how are you I'm good oh yeah
so [ __ ] good first of all I did not
fall asleep halfway through clerks like
Andrew there was something in my eye and
you guys are related I take it yeah
that's my son he's my dad yeah he's a
big fan of yours oh right on he has a
brain injury and I don't know there's a
correlation between those
oh my god okay spoken like my mother
clearly clearly not all these people
have a brain injury maybe just can't all
be brain injuries some people just like
it yeah
so Andrew and I have had a good time
hanging out with me and we watched
Facebook thing that making had done and
Andrew showed it to me before we came
down and so he talked about ketchup
chips they don't have in the States
yeah they don't and Tim Hortons all all
dressed chips we lie low with codeine so
I brought Ming some drugs I brought him
some tylenol with codeine
you brought me Ming Chen
over-the-counter drug yes the hard
streets of Prince George where you're
like here's some [ __ ] codeine buddy
huh drugs and titty bars what's wrong
with sometimes we take tylenol with
codeine go to the titty bar
that's Friday see but nobody else
brought him drugs so you know it's true
good boy and we brought him a couple of
bags of ketchup chips ketchup chips as
well yeah you guys are treating him
really well man yeah actually I met
Affleck I worked on reindeer games when
it was filming in Vegas did everybody
but you work in another city yeah there
I've spent years working in the film
industry but I gave him a copy in my
book he was the first first copy I got I
gave it to Affleck and then a friend of
mine started the rumor that Affleck
bought the rights to my book so
everybody thought I was gonna retire
because I had to dispel this rumor they
thought you had Mooney stir up together
you guys not true anyway the real
question when Andrew did see you in
Vancouver yes he was lined up wanted to
get he did the photo shoot and no yeah
and the lady said Kevin Smith will not
be signing autographs and we had gotten
Jay to do a poster when he was here a
couple years before yeah so he wanted to
get you to sign it and that works it was
so you know I don't know if we do it
later before doing not bring it on up
thank you on the worse he was and can I
this is not meant to be [ __ ] rude
because this person means a lot to me
but you and Mark might be able to back
me up and you might remember but a lot
of people in the audience wouldn't you
look like Captain Kangaroo thank you it
gives me such comfort it seems like
everybody knows somebody that looks like
me because they go you've been Albert I
know what uncle looks just like you you
know like my problem is I never met
Captain Kangaroo is a children's
television show hosts so like this is
the closest I've ever come well we can
get closer be like dear Andrew your dad
is creepy anyway thank you very much you
guys are your buddy stuff we grow garlic
make a line of honey garlic hot sauces
and I got a bottle with your name
fuckin'-a I'll take a bottle excellent
yeah absolutely thank you very much give
it up for Andrew and his dad man I wrote
I heart you and you're dead
all right here you go you take this bang
and that bang pleasure all right now
we're going to this cat hi welcome to
Prince George thank you big-ass pothole
but I would just have one question our
way would you be willing to accept a
gift from my girlfriend's mom who really
loves you
[Laughter]
miss your girlfriend named Stacy so this
is from your girlfriend's mom she didn't
come to the con no she couldn't
she's like I hear you're going to that
conure this is a silent ill guy yeah she
does have a booth and I just want to say
my life has been really good knowing
your films and stuff I think it's shaped
Who I am today thank you
oh my god it shaped me as well like
round for a while and then I started
losing weight because I had a [ __ ]
heart attack but thank you that means
the world
I too was shaped by movies if I ever met
the Coen brothers
I mean I've said it to John Landis I
never got to meet John Hughes he passed
away but I got to tell John Landis as
well like your [ __ ] movies shaped my
childhood and shaped Who I would later
become in life so I know what that means
thank you another question actually
totally oh I figured as much
sorry well anyway what the let's get
back to the mom thing what is it it's a
looks like a merkin like where since
we're in Canada it's a kind of plush
Bieber made out of so it is it's a
little plush beaver
yep I will
eh I'll gladly take that what a great
gift and a reminder of Prince George
Bobby I'll take it so I could call my
wife tonight and be like I caught so
much beaver what it is it's also from
her yes
this [ __ ] lady is nice man yeah bring
that she's one of the nicest people I
know bringing that yeah totally toss it
on a pyramid all right I just have one
more question yeah fire away
Oh so after the question you want to get
I want my [ __ ] first
I'm sorry me with the beaver and but I
am currently making a script for a movie
that I am directing right on and I just
want to ask is there any creative I like
information that you can tell me any
advice on script writing I'm gonna go
first because Marx is always better the
this is why I always tell young writers
novice writers or any writers even
[ __ ] writers who have been doing for
a long time but they tend to not want
your advice nearly as much write what
you know
like lionize yourself and your world
nobody else is ever going to so why not
take all the things you find fascinating
about yourself and your friends and your
world and [ __ ] write about that
that's the secret sauce nobody else has
that you know [ __ ] anybody can tell a
story about like heroes in space and
[ __ ] like that
nobody can tell your specific story and
that's what's original and stuff like
that that's what the best thing you got
going for you the best card to play is
your perspective so I always you know
say write what you know write the world
that you know put it up there for other
people to see that's all that's how I
got here I worked at a convenience store
I hung out with my friends we only
talked about movies TV shows and comic
books we were pop culture junkies and I
would go to the movies every week and I
would never see us up on the screen not
us personally but our world I know it
sounds weird to be a [ __ ] you know
middle-aged white man talking about
[ __ ] representation and movies but
it's gonna be mean later on but it was
there was a time where I was like I
don't recognize my world up here man I
want to see like people I know and
recognize and so that's that's what I
did and it's been the gift that's kept
on giving and yes I've written [ __ ] that
I don't know and stuff like Dogma I
don't know any rubber poop monsters in
real life but I did go to Catholic
school so I know a bunch of like
Christian mythology which really fueled
that [ __ ] movie and stuff I've always
just written what I've not but I've
known now thank God other people don't
like if George Lucas only wrote what he
knew
we wouldn't have Star Wars you know I'm
relatively sure he didn't like [ __ ]
right that based on real life like all
my shits based on like oh I dated a girl
and that's where chasing Amy came from I
never once heard George Lucas go like I
went to college with a wookie so you
know so of course you can make [ __ ] up
as well but my best advice is right well
you know lionize your [ __ ] world man
because that's gonna be unique to
somebody and why not put that up on
display but here comes better advice
right there I am going to say don't
write what you know contradictory god
damn it
well no here's what I will say I will
say that that much in the way Kevin says
that your life experience your
perspective on the world is different
and unique and and the thing that makes
you special but the world that you set
that story and the characters you said
that story and do not need to be
anything we've ever seen before because
George Lucas in Star Wars was very much
about what it's like to be a small-town
kid who wants something bigger who lives
a little bit outside the city who wants
fast cars who wants to be a hero
Tatooine is Prince George maybe where is
tashi station in this [ __ ] cuz I
need some power converters not around
here you know but it's it's the the idea
that that like Ryan Coogler in black
panther was writing his own story even
though it feels as if it's wild in
Wakanda and superheroes and magic metals
Universal it's Universal it's the
specific becomes Universal because it's
its own thing and and find a way to
insert yourself and your story in
whatever story you want to tell but
don't forget the why you're telling it
don't forget that your story is the only
way that that server could be but don't
be afraid to wrap it in almost anything
else I mean George junior Tolkien was a
world war one soldier who was writing
about the advance of militarization and
industrialization in his home country
and the Shire is England and the ring is
the advance of technology and you know
he lived through the worst attacks of
World War one and there's a scene in
mohabbat when they're walking through
the fields of the dead because he walked
through the fields of the dead like it's
finding ways to take your life
experiences and if your fantasy right if
here's your honor writer find ways to
inflect
the real-world residence into your
fantasy and then it becomes something
greater than just your story I'm
something greater than just any story
it's the only story you could tell so
don't be afraid to write what you know
and don't be afraid to make [ __ ] up
wildly but make it up only the way you
could okay hey and would you like ease
as well I don't feel I've earned them he
did but I'll take them that's for sure
a Beaver's mine toss it on up here man
I'll catch that [ __ ] my mouth it's got
some girth to it some weight to this
beaver it's been around it's delicate
okay I hope you're not delicate thank
you
what's her name Liam L I am is a lady do
you guys not know up here that that's a
man's name it's okay gender fluidity is
all good
Liam beautiful thank you man give it up
for this kid are you wearing a bandolier
around your butt is that it's part of a
cosplay that is [ __ ] tremendous more
people should do that you know what I'm
saying it's a good look and it's
practical you can put money and your
phone in there and stuff is it meant to
be like a chewy thing or is it meant to
be like a Batman belt I am one half of a
cosplay that competed earlier today I'm
Rocksteady and bebop is currently up in
the oh [ __ ] right on man I think that's
name hollering first of all it's an
honor to stand in front of such talent
and inspiration as well as a creativity
and just flat out podcast gods thank you
we're all so handsome sorry
bring it in a quick story about the fan
con we're Jason Mewes was here it was
entertaining to watch him because he
could not stand still and he would go
around naming off every single cosplay
as he went around
the entire area really it was impressive
yeah he's got a lot of nervous energy
I've seen it and also like when we were
younger he expressed it differently
like you know it now he'll walk around
and be like what's this what's this look
at that dog with a puffy tail but back
then he would express it like you'd be
driving somewhere with him and he'd be
like is it hot in here and you'd be like
what are you talking about and he would
look over and he'd pulled his pants down
so he's just [ __ ] his dick was out
he'd be like oh man
and he'd be like ha ha ha ha ha so I'm
glad his nervous energy manifests itself
differently now
well I won't repeat what happened at the
VIP parties very important penis quick
question for you guys in the world of
cancellations as well as reboots hunain
talking about Jay and Silent Bob reboot
if there's a series out there that has
either been cancelled or is on the verge
of canceling and you had the keys the
golden keys to say like take it it's
yours do as you wish with it what TV
series would you guys gladly reboot and
just take control over hmm in all
eternity from soup to nuts we can pick
something from like 40 years ago Captain
Kangaroo
were that much closer uh all right TV
show to reboot I would reboot Green
Hornet
I would I recall man you could totally
get away with that I I kind of love the
idea of of a Chinese superhero who needs
a rich white buffoon to bankroll his
crime-fighting
so it allows Britt Reid to just roll
with him like now you stay in the car
let me go and deal with this and you
just write the checks you be the the
iron fist to my Luke Cage you just you
just give me the car on the gear and
I'll go do this and you can take some
pictures at the end of the day
sounds like rush hour that's hysterical
well let me see what would i do well I
would do the it's a TV thing I don't
think it's like it's screaming to be
[ __ ] redone but it's a great concept
and it could easily be redone The
Greatest American Hero
which they made a pilot for and they
cast the girl from the new girl new girl
yeah Anna Simone is that her name that
is and then she just tweeted yesterday
that ABC I think was the network that
made it is not picking up the show so
they made a pilot and then that's it she
was going to be the first was
indian-american D an American superhero
yeah like ever but it didn't wind up
bless you moving forward so I think that
show could easily I thought they were on
a great path with it but you know
clearly ABC had other ideas
I would pick that it's a comic book show
that wasn't based on a comic book and
it's relatable and it's very relatable
yeah especially because it's not like
I'm from another planet I'm from Krypton
it's like you get given a suit that has
all these abilities but you lost the
instructions so you don't know how to
work it and stuff like that so it gives
you some comedy but it also allows you
to like build the universe doesn't one
thing they never did on that show was
like he never had a rogues gallery
he had a suit and everyone he fought was
like businessmen and [ __ ] like that
so you could make like a world of other
villains and other suits and stuff like
that I would go for that same answer I
like yours better
thank you thank you how are you my
friend really good thanks um I don't
want to bring the mood down by
continuing to bring up your recent heart
attack but no I'm always happy to talk
about because I lived through it it'd be
depressing to talk about if I died I
don't know how I'd have that
conversation I'm glad you're alive thank
you to mark didn't want to leave you out
there
do so what I was wondering is during
that trying time
were there any comic book moments or
stories or characters rankin a few
strengths absolutely but not as so much
gave me strength but gave me peace when
I was a kid I loved Neil Gaiman said
still do Neil Gaiman's Sandman books I
was got back into collecting comics
right when issue one had hit stands so I
was there from the jump and whatnot and
got to discover the endless and the
dreaming and all that great stuff so
about issue after the first main story
arc where he was getting back his his
stuff he met his sister they introduced
the character of death in the endless
and his sister looks like you know bless
you I like a goth kid wearing a knock
around her neck and stuff I'm sure I
don't have to tell this crowd maybe some
kids didn't read it and stuff but as
slowly throughout the issue you figure
out like there's something different
about her you know oh [ __ ] she's death
she's the personification of death it's
a wonderful [ __ ] story man one of the
greatest comic books I've ever read and
the character went on she had her own
miniseries and whatnot now game ins
doing a dreaming universe an endless
universe in DC Comics so we'll probably
see a lot more of these great characters
but in that issue they're walking around
New York and while she's talking to
dream who's in a bit of a funk about
having been captured for nearly a
hundred years and [ __ ] like that and
gone to battle he's talking to her she
is meeting people who are dying and
crossing them over as she is death and
so
there's a baby at one point that dies
there's a lady that dies then there's
this older man and he goes out kind of
bitter and he says something to the
effect of like I worked so hard and did
all these things and never got anything
what did I get you know I'm now I'm
dying what did I get
and the line that Gaiman attributes to
death which like I loved when I first
read it but had completely different
resonance as I was laying on the
operating table after the doctor was
like you've got you know 20% chance of
making it through this was this
incredible line where death says to the
old man she's like you got what
everybody gets you got a life and as I
sat there going like oh [ __ ] like I
might die I didn't get upset because I
thought of that I thought of that exact
[ __ ] line I was like you got a life
like this is this is what a life was and
you got to do some [ __ ] crazy cool
things your career was weird man you
survived that walrus movie like and you
had a family like you got to do what
your parents did before you and stuff
like that have sex and then have a kid
and build the family like you got a life
like and if it ends now at age 47 yeah
that's [ __ ] soon but like you know
what a great ride you did have you can't
[ __ ] about it that it's over too soon
maybe that's why clerks happened when
you were young because the [ __ ]
universe knew that you were gonna check
out at [ __ ] 47 so I thought
specifically about that lino gave me
absolute [ __ ] comfort like you got
what everybody gets you got a life
it taught me not to [ __ ] in that moment
I didn't sit there and go like oh [ __ ]
like blame people for my situation who
would I blame other than myself I didn't
try to bargain with God because I
assumed God would be like you made dogma
go [ __ ] yourself so I just I just was
faced with the notion of like oh you
might dying instead of being scared or
mad or bargaining or [ __ ] desperate
like I was just I felt grateful I was
like what a great life [ __ ] I got a life
that's what I got the other thing that
was like snot from comics but the other
thing that kept me going during the
operation I've talked about a lot of
talking about heart attack quite a bit I
promise one day I'll stop but right now
it's like the [ __ ] weirdest newest
thing that happened me but while I was
on the table at one point the doctor I
was I was singing not like [ __ ] top
of my lungs or anything like that
but kind of more chanting like a mantra
almost and the doctor dr. Leighton Heim
who's a cardiologist saved my life he
goes what is he singing and there was
another guy in the room who goes I think
he's singing the theme song to Degrassi
and I was I was singing the theme song
to Degrassi the next generation which is
one of the most hopeful [ __ ] songs
you'll ever hear in your life it's sung
by a choir of children and the lyrics
are so [ __ ] perfect it's whatever it
takes I know I could make it through and
as a guy on a table like trying to make
it through I was like I can think of no
better [ __ ] song to sing and so I
kept singing that over and over again
and so the guy recognized it he was like
that's Degrassi I said it is Degrassi
man
I said you watch it he's like I used to
and stuff he's like I haven't seen in a
few years I was like it's on Netflix
they took it over to Netflix now he goes
I haven't seen it yet I was like let me
tell you what's going on and the doctor
was trying to save my life was like can
you shut up we're trying to work here
and [ __ ] but I was pumped full of
fentanyl so I was real [ __ ] blazed
and whatnot so yeah there was comics
played a role man that moment in that in
that game and book and that line
attributed to death really played in my
in my head I wasn't looking for I wasn't
like boy I hope death shows up I was
fighting it I didn't want to go but at
the same time I was like if it ends
you got a life that's a great answer
thank you very much thank you my friend
sir I'm afraid you may be the last
question my friend so so yeah make it
make it a good one okay the other dude
asked about life and death so no
pressure oh nothing like that I know I'm
mostly it's mostly question for Kevin
there I'm a fan of yours thank you to my
most favorite things of yours is uh
clerks the animated series nobody ever
says my your dick and your balls exactly
yeah
clerks the anime tears I love the
clerk's anime series I can't take as
much credit for that though cuz I had a
lot of help including my co-conspirator
and and the guy who probably did the
most work Dave Mandel currently is the
show runner on veep he did the last
season and he's doing currently what
will be the last season of the show he
used to work on Seinfeld back in the day
he worked on Curb Your Enthusiasm for a
lot of years he's a comedic [ __ ]
genius and when we sat down to talk
about like this clerks cartoon he had
just come off of Seinfeld he had a deal
a touchstone TV and they said what do
you want to do and he was like I like
that movie clerks I want to do a clerks
cartoon so he came down a Red Bank New
Jersey and we sat there talking and we
got along instantly or from the same
kind of like not background he's from
like New York and lived in the city and
was like a city kid went to school there
and see part of the commentary on that
on that DVD series there because I
bought that there yeah it was great I
loved listening to that so when I sat
down with them you know I was like so
you want to make a black-and-white
cartoon and he was like no we would do
it in color and stuff and I was like and
it's gonna be like the movie Dan in life
he goes well since it's a cartoon we
could take like flights of fancy he's
gone like I'm just kind of using the
convenience store and the video stores
like pivot points and stuff and I was
like well what's like what do you mean
he's like well like my idea is like you
would could have a scene where Dante and
Randall are watching a movie and the
movie is Flintstones list because Steven
Spielberg had produced both Flintstones
the live-action movie and Schindler's
List in the same year so Dave who was
Jewish was just like I want to do this
bit where they're watching Flintstones
List and I was like what is it he goes
well we cut to the movie itself and we
show like you know a Nazi guard but he
looks like a caveman it's all drawn like
the Flintstones and then he says load
them up and then we see a bunch of
prisoners getting loaded onto a train
and then the door closes and this train
presumably headed to a in a
concentration camp door closes on the
train he says
then all their feet come out and the
Train walks away so I was like I want to
work with you so he gets a lot of credit
I'll give him all the credit he is in
fact the voice of like one of the things
people love in that show is when we do
the Korean animation when it comes back
from overseas and they're like they just
did their best they could and [ __ ] so we
had this animated sequence like always
planned and it's very colorful and
[ __ ] anime like but Dave at the last
minute was like do you think anyone's
gonna get the joke man like maybe we
need to like have people talking through
it and stuff and I was like what do you
mean he's like well the idea would be
like the Korean animators provided like
an audio track or something and I was
like let's record it and if it works
we'll keep it if not no worries so jump
in the booth so no prep whatsoever he
just jumped in the booth with the
microphone on him and then just watched
the animation and just made the [ __ ] up
as he went along and [ __ ] so Dave is at
the top of his head is responsible for
like who is driving bear is driving how
can that be [ __ ] like that
very very funny guy okay so my question
is since well I said that clerks the
clerk's series was my favorite they're
my absolute favorite thing of yours is
Mallrats
oh thank you what binge watched that
show over and over and I used to learned
the opening dialogue I used to know it
off by heart but it's been a while since
I when Brody tells the story yeah about
the hamster the butthole there yes and
the reason why he had to keep getting
but oh how adorable is a cat how
adorable that it you're in this room
sitting in front of mr. Kersey mouth and
you're like the butthole I think it
might sound a little better actually you
know its butthole it sounds softer it
does yes kind of romantic oh we're out
doing your shoving cats up there you
know what I'm saying too early so my
question is will there be a mall rat
sequel there was I was trying there was
a mall rats to script that I'd written
and then I didn't know in the movie so I
couldn't make it Universal is like we're
not really interested in making that so
I was like [ __ ] then universe
TV was like hey why don't you do as a TV
show and I was like [ __ ] ya and I built
a series and then we pitched it four
places and all four of them like oh my
god I love mall rats it was my religion
when I was a kid I was it great well
here's mall rats - and at the end of it
they're like thanks and that was it so
four places it was kind of disconcerting
and then I was like I don't want to do
this anymore like this is [ __ ] is
disconcerting so just quietly rode off
into the sunset I just put it to the
side and there's still places to go
which it like I said to myself one day
I'll go back out with it but in that
moment instead of like just licking my
wounds I was like [ __ ] plag I kept
trying to play with my toys like clerks
were my toys but I sold it to Miramax so
they owned it so I you know and also I
couldn't make a clerks sequel without
everyone's involvement and stuff so
suddenly I was thwarted from playing
with my toys Mallrats the same thing
those are my toys but they are owned by
somebody else as thwarted from playing
with my [ __ ] toys so I was like you
know what stop trying to play with toys
you don't own anymore like you own two
toys Jay and Silent Bob play with those
and so that's when I started working on
Jay and Silent Bob reboot now if it
works believe me I'm gonna go back in
and be like hey man I got this mall rat
show and [ __ ] like that maybe the timing
was off so I'm not giving up hope great
that's awesome thank you very much thank
you and I think that's all the time we
have you want to be we got we got this
like three people left let's just hit
him real quick go ahead well you
mentioned Lucifer as a sympathetic
character before and with all these
villains being approached as sympathetic
characters like Lucifer and that was
what would be your favorite villain to
write as a movie from a sympathetic
standpoint both of you I'm tempted to
say Darth Vader but like that's what
that whole prequel trilogy was about and
we all thought we wanted that and then
they gave it to him or like now I'm good
I would do Submariner I would do Namor I
think I think there's a lot of meat on
those bones there's a lot of tragedy you
know I mean every every hero every
villain is the hero of his own story so
what's name was origin story what does
he want that he can't have and what is
the thing that's in the way of what he
wants are the superheroes of the Marvel
Universe and that's kind of fun so yeah
I would go Submariner he's been done
though a bunch Magneto I'd rather do
somebody that hasn't been like as well
covered let me see a magneto is kind of
automatically sympathetic yeah right he
is kind of sympathetic so he's not my
fault I was just a big blinky I'm an
maybe if I'd another I I wouldn't feel
so [ __ ] angry but evidently a musical
the musical of Sauron I'm just an eye
guy I see you I see me in pain and agony
if only I had a ring let me see who'd be
a good villain the [ __ ] I miss
counter what they did with that last pan
movie right they kind of did the origin
of Captain Hook and made him mmm
sympathetic well I mean if we're gonna
pull from comics I would go with Doctor
Doom we've yet to have a really great
Doctor Doom and you know like that's
what I like about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and what they were able to
accomplish with Thanos like those of us
who love comics know Thanos and the
Infinity Gauntlet and [ __ ] like that but
like that is not a well-known character
like you can't you know if you say
Doctor Doom your mom goes oh I've heard
of Doctor Doom but if you're like fan oh
sure mom's like what but now after those
movies after ten years of making those
movies and turning Thanos into a [ __ ]
major character like an incredibly
compelling villain with a
great backstory like they didn't need
dr. doom they didn't need Galactus they
didn't need any of their big [ __ ]
Bad's that they had that they gave away
with the other properties they turned
Thanos into like an incredibly memorable
[ __ ] villain and stuff so yeah in the
hands of somebody but since since they
were able to do that with Thanos Doctor
Doom is kind of a similar character to
some degree I would like to I'd see that
I'll give you one more oh go I want to
set the stage it's a it's a it's a
forest there's a cabin in the forest and
inside the cabin is an old man and his
young grandson and the old man is very
very sick
he's got the consumption let's call it
the consumption cuz why not and so they
they haven't eaten in a good long time
and so they the young boy you know takes
it upon himself he takes his
grandfather's rifle down off a thing and
loads it with a little bit of buckshot
and and walks out I swear grandad I'll
be right back I just got to get
something we have to eat something if
not it's gonna be the end of the road
it's this kids like wandering through
the snow and he makes his way and he
sees something in the distance and he
holds up the gun kind of shaky and he
kills Bambi's mom pretty much perfect
please I should stop based on that he's
the one that should be making movies
thank you well done give it up for him
great question thank you how are you
huge fan of the flash oh I love that
show and you were really good with Grant
Gustin thank you what do you mean good
we like talking to him behind the scenes
yeah yeah I'm very good at behind the
scenes on the scenes not great but
behind the scenes like I'm real good at
that [ __ ]
and I seen them and I seen that the
flash when you were one of the villains
and I'm like oh cool this is Kevin
she's amazing with the flow like um with
whatever you were doing and it was so
funny I've been waiting my whole life
for me to hear somebody say you're
amazing at whatever you're doing I was I
was on a most recent episode the one
that I directed where me and both Jay
and I were there and we were playing
museum guards very Abbott and Costello
like museum guards and stuff but I loved
that show as well I just watched the new
episode two days ago yeah and I am I
kind of do my own acting I kind of act
like I'm Sarah Allen Oh get out of here
really yeah what just in life in general
and stuff um well I kind of I kind of
say to Barry I'm like I'm gonna go like
Sarah she runs off and she goes see her
dad in prison and I kind of remember the
whole scene what grant says my name is
Barry Allen I'm the fastest man alive to
outside world I am for instance
scientist but secretly with the help of
my friends at STAR Labs I fight crime
and find other metahumans like me
and one day I'll find who killed my
mother and get justice for my father I
am the flash you just gave me chills man
well done I've never memorized that
that's one of my that they start the
show that way like it gets me like
especially with that music Blake Neely's
music on it you like yeah what could
save the world Barry do it in 45 minutes
I hope you come back next year oh if
they bring me back I'll come back in a
[ __ ] heartbeat it's beautiful up here
can I tell you a little something about
how they make that show the flash now
that I've done it a few times so you
know how whenever he runs into a room or
leaves a room and just the stuff every
the wind blows and everything goes
flying and [ __ ] like that
one of my favorite aspects of the show
because he spends all of his time with
the smartest people in the world and
then he leaves and [ __ ] papers go fly
and they're so smart they never figured
out like a [ __ ] paperweight would
make their lives so much easier so I
love that aspect of it it's called the
Zoop
like when he comes into a scene and
leaves the scene it's called souping and
I asked the ad Bob I was like
Bob I read in the script that says flash
soups into the room and he goes yeah
yeah that's when it comes in real
[ __ ] fast and the wind blows and I
says OOP I've never heard that word
again he goes oh that's cuz the guy who
directed the pilot he don't know comics
at all I was like so and he goes well he
was here on the first day and he goes
okay I'm reading the script here let's
see what happens the fast guy is gonna
zip in here and those up over there and
it was a poet Aaron's ups out of the
room and so and so the writers were like
0ps so they changed it and stuff I said
I love that Zoop Bob I can't wait to see
that [ __ ] you guys how you do it and
[ __ ] he goes oh that's right you don't
know how we do the soup do you and I
said no and he goes boy you're in for a
[ __ ] disappointment I was like why he
goes you'll see man we're doing it in
two days and [ __ ] and then it came time
to do it and what now is the first time
I saw Grant in the costume like you know
I've seen the show obviously but in real
life feeling turned around he was in the
[ __ ] costume and I was took my breath
away man it's like it's impressive in
real life and you'd be you know immature
to be like oh I saw him in the costume
my dick got hard because that's not what
happened my [ __ ] got wet man cuz oh my
god he looks so [ __ ] amazing and [ __ ]
like that
so I was like this is great man oh my
god we're gonna [ __ ] start with the
soup you're gonna zoom into the scene is
you're a zoop right at the top and he
goes you're so excited I was like I've
never shot a soup before I don't know
how you guys do the soup he goes oh
that's right you don't know how he
accomplishes the soup do you I said no
and he goes boy you're in for a
disappointment I said guess what Bob
said and so Bob goes 'i ready to do this
i said yeah go set up a shot tell me
what you want to do is okay as i want
Joe and an iris and Cisco they'll be in
the foreground with their backs to the
camera and in the mid-ground nothing in
the back deep background that's where
the door is to the breach room he'll
flash will Zoop in and then the scene
begins and then Bob is like okay just
give me a second here is there's gonna
be two calls for action there's action
camera and then action grant is okay you
guys just give me ten seconds between
each don't don't say action yet until
[ __ ] we do action grant there's ten
seconds I just need a plate shot so they
just shoot the empty frame because
digital
they'll add the lightning and stuff so
it's okay and so we said action and the
actors just froze like children playing
freeze tag in front of the camera and
stuff and ten seconds is a long [ __ ]
time when grown-ass adults are like this
like you just start to question your
direction in life and stuff you're like
is this what I do for a living is so
strange it just seems immature and then
after 10 seconds
Bob the ad is like okay grant come in
and then grant just walks into the
doorway and stands they're just normal
dressed in his full outfit and [ __ ] and
then Bob goes okay action grant and then
grant goes what did I miss
and then the scene begins that is the
soup that little hop step
because digitally they'll add the
lightning and then suddenly he's there
he won't be there and then suddenly he's
there so all they do is that little
[ __ ] hop thing which looks so stupid
that I laughed out loud and blew the
take altogether because it wasn't what I
was expecting man and they were like you
know grant was Bob the ad goes who's
laughing and grant goes the director and
I was like do you guys [ __ ] realize
the way you shoot the flash the way I
used to play the flash on the playground
it's [ __ ] crazy but as [ __ ] weird
as it is to watch him Zoop into a scene
like at least it makes sense you're over
the awkwardness pretty quickly cuz a
scene begins he races in and then the
drama starts you know here's the problem
and here's how we solve it so he'll Zoop
in he'll do that little move and then
you know [ __ ] the scene goes on so
you kind of forget about the little move
but when he has to Zoop out of a scene
it's [ __ ] even more precious because
essentially like the tension is rising
and they're like Barry you gotta save
the Sidney he's like I'm on it [ __ ]
and then he's still there yeah and then
he just has to walk away like Charlie
Brown and [ __ ]
cuz he can't really run fast it's
[ __ ] awesome the other part of it is
like why the wind blows is there's
somebody right off camera holding what
looks like a flamethrower a giant
flamethrower it's an air cannon and when
he comes in when he does his Zoop step
they turn that [ __ ] air cannon on and
like 4,000 pounds of air pressure blast
everyone else in their face neck and
chest like a oxygenated porno and it's
just so [ __ ] weird to watch man
because you're watching normal people
and they know that the air cannons
coming they're all really great actors
but like they know what it feels like so
if you watch real closely you'll watch
you'll see their eyes go that was for
real for real for real yes that was for
real forever and and when I was what
they watch they have all three of them
yes and what I kind of looked at I'm
like why's Grant has like was it
sabotage and stuff and it was like whoa
2 grands what the heck yeah that's some
of that special effects stuff they do
right where they shoot him once and they
put makeup on i'ma shoot my second time
they just combine those things alright
we're good excellent talking dude give
it up for our ladies gentlemen this is
it you're the last one you're gonna
close this out man how are you what's
your name and we'll give it up for Kyle
our reservation and everything see you
thank you it's amazing thanks man
far away when movies are being made into
Netflix it seems like Netflix would
accept anything into movies well not
mall rats
I tried real hard and they were like we
think we found our line well my question
is um why don't why don't you just make
a movie in Netflix I think you would
kill it I would love to I would love to
be in the Netflix business but so far
anything I've gone into Netflix with
they've been like thank you come again
and I've left and nothing's come of it
I've thought for a minute they would
want to make moose jaws which is jaws
but with a moose instead of a shark but
they didn't go for that either we found
somebody who wants to make moose jaws
which is really nice but it wasn't
Netflix so they're they're in the
business there they're like they get
huge people now like you know they just
made that Ryan Murphy deal where they're
paying him like I got a hundred million
dollars he's the guy that American crime
story American Horror Story anything was
Shonda Rhimes she got a hundred million
Shonda Rhimes Shonda LAN you know
[ __ ] a Grey's Anatomy and all those
shows so they're working with like major
talent that [ __ ] draws like you know
I'm a nostalgia act for them they're
like oh that's right you made that
clerks movie once you know so I I don't
know I don't know that the that they
would they thus far I mean I know for a
fact I've pitched a lot of things and
they haven't gone for him like at one
point we pitched buckaroo banzai and I
was like oh my god Netflix will take
this but it wasn't Netflix it was Amazon
wanted it more so yeah I don't know man
it's funny it's like there's a guy who
runs Netflix Ted Saran knows who I've
known for years just through in the
business and then one day he wound up at
Netflix when it was still will mail you
a DVD and then you mail it back and [ __ ]
like that
then netflix became what it became and
so Ted is like you know he's overnight
became one of the most important people
and [ __ ] show business and stuff so
every time I see him at Netflix whenever
I go to pitch something at Netflix and
this is not an exaggeration invariably I
have run into Ted in the lobby and he
always comes up he's a cab in Howard
you and I'm like hey man how are you
only chit-chatting I love what you guys
are up to and [ __ ] and he's like what
are you here with and I tell him he's
like man I hope we pick it up and they
never pick it up it never happens it's
almost like I leave him in the lobby I'm
like bye and he gets on the phone and he
goes know for silent bill I don't know
what it is man but it's so crazy so I
went in recently what was the last thing
I went in with something with Mitch
Albom I went in with to pitch something
and I was telling him and another guy we
were with they were like if you ever
pitched here before and it was the first
time I was in the new Netflix building
and Netflix built this I mean I got all
the money in the world so they built
this gorgeous [ __ ] office space where
you walk in and the walls are just video
walls so it's constantly evolving ads
for all their shows so you walk through
like Buckingham Palace because of the
what's that trend I do the crown and so
forth and so on it's really [ __ ]
impressive and stuff and so we were
there in the lobby and it was [ __ ]
packed like it looked like Grand Central
Station and so they were like you ever
been here before us I've been Netflix I
pitch to Netflix but not the new place
this is gorgeous I said but I'll tell
you what man I said because he goes how
many times you pitched here I said many
times they've never bought anything I've
ever done I said but my theory about
that is every time I've come here I bump
into Ted Saran dose and I chitchat with
them and then they don't pick anything
up so as long as we don't bump into Ted
Saran dose this morning I think we might
get picked Kevin and I turned around and
it's [ __ ] Ted Saran dose and they
look at me and they're like it's over
I'm like it is over like I want to talk
to Ted he's like what are you doing I
was like I'm here to pitch something
with these cats and stuff and we went in
in pitch and they didn't say no but they
still haven't said yes so I don't know I
don't know if I'll ever be able to find
a home on Netflix I would love to man
because I [ __ ] they got enough of my
money I'd like to take some of theirs
back you know and I'm saying I paid a
lot into that Netflix corporation be
nice if they were like here's a check
for you to go off to make Mallrats but I
don't think that's gonna happen
that's kind of sad to hear like what a
[ __ ] bummer man
but it doesn't have to be Netflix I mean
look we all know love Netflix cuz it's
everywhere and it's easily accessible
and even your mom knows how to work it
and [ __ ] like my mom like the one time I
showed her Netflix I've never had to
show her again like you know every other
thing in life she's been like I
understand how this works and but
Netflix she gets it's fluid the
interface is fantastic gives her access
to lots of material I love Netflix but
Netflix is not the only game in town you
know it's like if I can't find a home
there there's plenty places that don't
want to work with me I'm proud to say
and so I've never found it had a problem
finding a home eventually if it ain't
them it'll be somebody else and I've
always subscribed to the Coen brothers
school of storytelling or or conducting
your business Coen Brothers started in
this business making the weirdest
[ __ ] movies that were around at the
time very left-of-center very different
than everything else and you know most
young filmmakers or first-time or of
anything you know you got the fire of
the passion your belly and stuff so you
tend to be weird and do weird things and
take chances and eventually you calm
down and get with the program over time
and stuff Coen Brothers never did that
Coen Brothers just kept making weird
[ __ ] their whole [ __ ] career man and
even when they're like hey it's Fargo
and everybody loves it they followed it
up with a movie that like you wouldn't
imagine would follow Fargo but now
everybody loves which is the big
lebowski and so like they're glue
everywhere with their [ __ ] career
never once did they move the line or go
to the conventional like they set up
their shop here and the business of
everything else was over here and you
know conventional wisdom dictates that
slowly over the course of their career
they gravitate toward the places that
[ __ ] finance things and start working
more conventionally and they never did
they kept making the same weird [ __ ] and
the weirdest [ __ ] thing happened the
business just slowly [ __ ] came over
to them and started working their way as
well so
whenever I go into a place and they
don't [ __ ] see it through my vision
like you know they can't you can't
always hear yes it's it's you know this
business that's a lot of [ __ ] no and
I've actually heard more yes than know
along of course in my career but when no
happens it happens and it sucks cuz it
feels like oh [ __ ] my ideas suck or
whatever the [ __ ] but I don't succumb to
that I just go like you know what it
won't be here like just keep doing your
[ __ ] thing I know I'm not the Coen
Brothers but like I'm inspired by
anyone's ability to stick with
themselves to bet on themselves over and
over again there have been times in my
career where I did not bet on myself
where I was like what are they doing
over there let me do what's conventional
and like Zack and Miri Make a Porno is
that that's me going like oh my god Judd
Apatow is doing well making my movies
let me try to make a Judd Apatow movie
and [ __ ] it didn't really work out
that way to thine own self be true as
they said in Hamlet and I could kind of
believe that because at the end of the
day you can't guarantee success on any
level right like you'd be lucky to make
a thing can't guarantee people are gonna
love it and [ __ ] like that
so you might as well love it like make
sure that you [ __ ] love the thing
make sure you're not doing something for
somebody else just because you're like
well at least that'll get me in the
[ __ ] door or whatever do your thing
and eventually hopefully they'll come
around like they did with the Coen
brothers but if they don't you just have
your own [ __ ] thing which is its own
[ __ ] prize like you get to show
people like this is me this represents
me and maybe if you keep quietly
consistently [ __ ] doing it staying
true to yourself eventually people come
over and follow and stuff so I don't
sweat like not being picked up on
Netflix it [ __ ] sucks but like look I
grew up fat and I never had a big dick
so I'm used to disappointment
good thank you my friend
pleasure that concludes the Q&A portion
of the show and as we look up at the
clock its is it really 10 o'clock is
really 10 o'clock two and a half hours
that concludes the show in general
ladies and gentlemen have you had a good
time this evening if you did thank the
good folks of northern fan Conn who
brought us up here to Prince George to
play with you all man to this beautiful
part of the [ __ ] country honored to
sit here and geek out with everybody on
a Saturday night
happy Mother's Day in advance to all
those mothers out in the audience and
and whatnot I think there's two but but
this show is only as interesting as it
is and fun as it is because we got a
real writer sitting in on the show give
it up for the amazing mr. mark Bernard
Shaw and that is fat man I'm Batman for
this week I'm Kevin Smith I am mark
Bernard tune in next week same fat time
same fat Channel spot Kiska more
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith and I
Bridge George
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you